welcome to the day a u.s president joe
biden's facing mounting political
pressure over a shortage of baby formula
the supply chain disruption began when
the largest formula manufacturing plant
in the u.s had to close because of
safety concerns now the president has
invoked the defense production act to
revive domestic supplies and to allay
the fears of worried parents
while americans got used to certain
products missing from supermarket
shelves during the pandemic the shortage
of this product could potentially be
life threatening baby formula
a nightmare especially for mothers who
are unable to breastfeed blake blake jr
and i started to see that there was a
formula shortage i was telling my
husband
i said honey we gotta go and find this
formula because this is a crisis he said
everything's gonna be all right you know
all of a sudden we go to buy formula
everything is gone
it all started in february when top u.s
manufacturer abbott laboratories had to
close their plant in michigan after
recalling formulas
babies became sick with bacterial
infections after consuming the products
at least two infants died to battle the
shortage u.s president joe biden invoked
the defense production act it requires
suppliers of formula manufacturers to
fulfill their orders before delivering
to other customers he also authorized
special flights to import supplies from
overseas i've directed the department of
defense and the department of health and
human services to send aircraft planes
overseas
to pick up infant formula that meets u.s
health and safety standards so we can
get it on the store shelves faster
the shortage has sparked a search of
interest at milk banks
mothers are increasingly coming here to
feed their children with donated milk
from other women
we were able to come here and get
as many bottles as we need it to keep
her fed and keep her growing um this
past week when we called um
there just wasn't any available so it's
been pretty scary um
to
to realize that you might not be able to
feed your baby right so
it's a public health crisis that could
easily turn into a political crisis for
the biden administration
the u.s president will be hoping his
executive action will end the shortage
and prevent further political fallout
let's start on that question with amber
phillips who's been covering this story
for the washington post welcome to dw
how is this playing politically for the
president
yeah well there was just a hearing today
where the head of the agency that's
supposed to be monitoring baby formula
and and
inspecting that plant in michigan that
had those potential safety bacterial
infection problems
told congress we're investigating we're
working on this every day
but the that person was blasted by both
members of congress democrats and
republicans saying
you had a whistleblower report about
this from october uh
you know at least one member of congress
said i told you about an infant death in
my community in september and yet the
fda didn't jump in to try to investigate
this plan until december
uh in between that time infants were
hospitalized and died and this is all
exacerbated the food the shortage of
infant formula so the point i'm trying
to make here is that
this government agency here in america
has some tough questions to answer about
why they didn't act sooner on this um
and why they didn't foresee a crisis
coming if this major plant in america of
a major manufacturer
had to pull formula from the shelves so
the biden administration more broadly
has yet to answer questions about that i
think right now they're just focused in
crisis mode right um arguably months
later
and
are all mothers in the same boat on this
or are there geographical or social
differences
uh yes and note about those questions
all mothers are in the same boat it is
very difficult no matter your
socioeconomic level to find formula
however
there have been researchers who say it's
more difficult for lower income women
and that's because a lot of them rely on
coupons from the government to buy
formula they can only buy specific
formulas so congress today
just passed a bill that will change that
and allow them to buy whatever they see
on the shelves
rural areas you also have reports of
mothers driving hundreds of miles to a
food bank where they hear that there's
formula and then it also affects women
who don't have time resources or child
care to take off to go to eight
different target big box stores here in
america to find formula and you hinted
at
the sort of the crux of this problem it
does seem odd that
the closure of one factory can cause all
this disruption
yeah there are four major formula
manufacturers in the us the united
states
does not if ever import formula although
that's changing now with this crisis as
the military actually rushes to try to
get formula from abroad over here to the
u.s
and and and in addition as i said
low-income women in particular have to
buy a certain formula and the government
restricts them and there's no
flexibility in times of crisis or
natural disaster
or supply chain issues and so these are
all
very systemic problems
that i i think the broader community
here in america didn't think about until
all of a sudden you heard the pain in
that mother's voice moms can't feed
their babies or they're scared they
can't
and doctors of course are warning
against making up your own baby formula
these so-called homebrews
my kids are just out of the formula
stage but i know from my mom community
here here where i live uh in america
that
when you call your pediatrician and say
what do i do
there are no other options other than to
go to the store and look for formula and
and deal with the rations and deal with
the lines and deal with the time off
work there are no other options as you
just said
doctors say don't make your own formula
don't wean your child off this before
they're one don't try giving them cow's
milk
alone
figure out a way to get formula and it's
it's it's like it's one thing after
another there's we've covered and we
have the cost of living crisis inflation
uh close to a 40-year high and people
struggling to afford food shelter and
even fuel
it's not a good look for democrats if
we're going to talk about this
politically and of course president
biden and his party are trying to keep
control of congress and whatever
governor's mansions and legislate
legislators they still have control of
in november's midterm elections
it is not a good look when republicans
can say look in america in 2022
where's the baby formula especially when
it points the timeline as we know right
now it's still early in the story points
to
the administration not responding
quickly enough to this crisis or
foreseeing it at the very least
so
briefly then um
the abbott factory has now been cleared
to restart and between that and the the
president's crisis measures where is it
um predicted that baby formula will be
back on the shelves
we're hearing a broad range which is
frustrating for moms and dads trying to
find formula it could be weeks to even
months the head of this agency the fda
told congress that the really hard part
is going to be distributing formula to
rural areas in particular so those
people who really need it could be the
last to get it all right we wish you
well thank you so much for uh joining us
and explaining that to us amber phillips
from the washington post
thank you